and I genuinely have had this a couple
of times oh you can come clean my house
I've actually had someone say that to me
[Music]
the big thing for me I think about
general life is how people think OCD is
not really serious a lot of people are
happy to say I'm the vet OCD I love
certain TV shows and I obsessed with
them and I compulsively watch them over
and over again until the end yeah it's
not a disorder because I'm not
distressed about it I love it yeah
OCD is a disorder and yeah it's not
something that's that you want to do if
you do it and you say it's OCD and you
like it it's not a CD yeah I think the
hardest thing for me is that when you
get to a point where OCD is so
debilitating that you just can't
function yeah and then when you're at a
point where you can function and work
and and sort of live a normal life using
a phrase people assume that you've got
better and it's gone away and I think
what's really hard for me to express the
people is the unpredictability whereby
there can be situations at work that
don't affect my OCD at all and then one
thing can happen that completely sends
me into a spiral yeah and can just shut
me down for the day
I would say that it's something that
dominates your whole sort of experience
of life and I would describe it probably
as straining and restricting and taking
away of freedom really for me it's just
questioning every single facet of life
and thoughts so it's the fact that they
never stop yeah and there's a relentless
and exhausting
yeah the by is something that I don't
think people realize like the mental
side of it it really takes the toll OCD
is about a way to stay safe in a way to
feel safe like you're following
guidelines rules that you've been given
and if you deviate from any of those
rules that have been set out for you
something's gonna happen
people sometimes look at people with
mental health problems whatever it is
and think that they're gonna be needy in
a relationship and I think when I have
relationship issues and people around me
and like our friends and stuff look in
on the situation they automatically
think oh well James has got mental
health problems so therefore like he's
the problem
yeah and it must be really really
difficult for the other one you know
poor them and everything whereas
actually a lot of the time I think
because I've struggled with certain
things I might have a bit more empathy I
can be quite patient and then also that
I find it really difficult to ask for
help in general so I'm not very
demanding and I'm not needy at all I
think for me it's that like my OCD can
be quite visible and I would carry a lot
of shame about some of the stuff that I
have to do and I think that's really
hard when you have to let someone else
be present and see that and I think that
certainly had an effect on how open I've
been to find in love and being with
people like OCD has affected every part
of my life including like my sex life
and how that operates and feels and
works and I think what's really hard is
acknowledging that myself and it's taken
years and years and years to need yet be
able to say I actually sometimes find
talking about sex and having sex really
difficult yeah and that's something that
we don't even talk about sex anyway
they're talking about a mental health
issue and sex is just like a major nono
you you pigeonhole yourself with this
idea of are mentally oh I've got an
illness you define yourself by that I
think when you're first in those throws
figuring out where you fit in in society
being mentally ill is just a tiny tiny
tiny part of what makes up you as a
person in the same way I felt like an
alien
it really did I felt like so isolated
from other people because I didn't talk
to anyone else about it nobody really
got it nobody wanted to know I wasn't
able to go to school as in other places
to me people who are my age more
recently is that I want to take part and
to fit in and join in activities with
friends and be part of groups I find it
difficult to not be invited to things
sometimes not to be asked to do things
because like I'm not able to cope as
well as everyone else I'm able to go
really really well I have just very
unhealthy ways to cope sometimes but I
still want to be asked I think I want to
be incoming it's it's that you know you
want the permission to turn something
down or say no or say actually that
might be a choice
yeah the choice I think that's the thing
I would want them to know that they're
not an alien it isn't the end of the
world it doesn't mean that their life is
gonna be hard
forever and it doesn't mean that they're
not gonna be able to enjoy life and I
would want people to realize that hope
is there and it's not the end everything
passes things can get better with the
right half and the right support try and
talk to try and break the silence and to
break the dominance of this feel like
you've been heard a little bit about it
and then trying to go and get some help
for it and it's not your fault for
having it in the first place and it's
not your fault that it's difficult to
get better from it it's your strengths
that you've been able to get a diagnosis
in the first place they have been able
to come forward with it and recognising
all those positive things as well
[Music]